so I said on Twitter because Fredo died  Christie's all right ways and I  genuinely got really angry just  preemptively I'm like i whatever russ is  about to say I just wanted to just  [ __ ] write it down and eat that paper  yeah and then just go do something else  yeah so I said shut the [ __ ] up Russ  whatever you guys say nobody wants to  hear it  haters gonna hate and aina is gonna  ain't sorry read that again  haters gonna hate and a nurse gonna  ain't a nurse a nurse painters Inter's  gonna ain't ya I should reply to this  and be like birds gonna fly and you know  moles gonna dig like what a incredibly  stupid incredibly stupid just statement  its dog fish gonna swim and bro really  snap bro really scoffs honestly bro  gonna bra snap gonna say that wasn't  smart say that legit to someone in real  life and just watch their face like yeah  well  [Music]  got some fun these are Dustin phone  these are dusty all in my bag on my  wrists Oliver